let's go to Wonderland Alice in
Wonderland I went into this movie with
[ __ ] expectations after Tim Burton's
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory some
about I mean just you just started to
piss me off and everything in the
trailer for this movie looks like just
horrible CGI the Red Queen had a huge
head she looks like some sort of
marionette horror baby so I wasn't
looking forward to it but I actually
liked it a lot more than I thought I
would
it takes place 13 years after Alice in
Wonderland so instead of a rien
visioning is actually a sequel I'm
pretty sure Burton did this way because
if he didn't he wouldn't be able to have
Johnny Depp and most of the movie and
who we kiddin Depp is just the Burton
bread and butter but this movie isn't
actually the Johnny Depp showcase I
thought it would be I mean it still kind
of feels like the Johnny Depp show but
Alice is still the main point so that
was cool and the Alice in this movie is
exactly what you'd expect from a girl
who tripped balls and went to Wonderland
13 years prior meThe doubt pale white
skin dark circles around the eyes
Tim Burton then again how sound would
any of us look if someone laced our [ __ ]
with absinthe and sent us down a rabbit
hole when we were six years old I mean
the girl didn't stand out a zillion
other chicks could have played Alice in
this movie but she didn't suck so I'm
okay with it and it has all the
characters you remember from Alice in
Wonderland a Tweedles via bad CGI that
caterpillar didn't hi I'm hookah the
Cheshire Cat who was really really cool
in this movie he was probably my
favorite and I really messed up rabbit I
don't remember him like this in the
cartoon Alice in Wonderland but in this
movie he's all like it's so warm I see
the teats cutest [ __ ] just give it a to
English it so the premise of this
movie's Alice needs to beat the [ __ ] out
of the Jabberwocky and when you see the
Jabberwocky you're gonna think the exact
same thing I did you're gonna be like
holy [ __ ] is that hillbilly man-bat from
Jeepers Creepers it looks just like him
even has that that that finn thing that
happens with his face when he's pissed
off that's right ladies and gentlemen
the creeper makes an appearance in alice
in wonderland
no it's rated PG but there are some
scenes where kids might I don't know
freak out there's a scene where Alice
needs to cross a moat of blood by
stepping on the heads severed heads
so if severed heads freak your kids out
you might want to pass on this one or at
least that scene or two so it's overuse
of CGI pissed me off shut up
that's different this had bad CGI in
some scenes like the Tweedles and making
everyone weird and unproportioned it was
just unnecessary like the knave of
hearts his bodies all stretched out
which means it's CGI which means he
moves like this alright let's go
let's kill people all right yes I'm the
knave of hearts let's do it here's my
sword let's kill him the knave of Hearts
being played by Crispin Glover whose
greatest roles include George McFly from
Back to the Future and almost kicking
David Letterman in the head on his own
show it's in the sidebar go check it out
you need to see it because it's just
that awesome but as for Alice in
Wonderland if you take your family to
see it you're all going to have a good
time it's definitely worth a family
night out but if you're one of those
people that have been following this
movie ever since like Marilyn Manson was
going to direct it or some [ __ ] in the
90s and the hot topic gods just demand
that Marilyn Manson Alice in Wonderland
vision you might be disappointed but if
for nothing else the Tim Burton Alice in
Wonderland is infinitely better than the
Tim Burton Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory it seemed to end a little fast
but it's ready PG for god sakes your
kids are not going to give a [ __ ] and if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more than click on the other
link in the sidebar to see more videos
that's right in a world of $15 a ticket
3d movies I gave you free entertainment